-For the past 20 years, singer
R. Kelly has faced accusations
of sleeping with underage girls,
filming sexual encounters
without women's consent,
and even running a sex cult.
Recently he released
a 19-minute song called
"I Admit It."
Here to comment on that song,
please welcome one of our
writers, Amber Ruffin,
with "Amber's Minute of Fury."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right now all across America,
black people are imprisoned for
tiny, insignificant infractions.
Meanwhile, this fool
is skipping around
freer than a lady
in a tampon commercial.
So, in this new song,
which I haven't listened to
and never will,
R. Kelly tried to defend
his horrible behavior.
In his song, he says all
kinds of crazy things like,
"I just want to do my music.
Stop stressing me."
Okay, no one's mad at you
for doing your music.
No one is saying
that that song is too young.
No one's saying don't have sex
with that song on tape
without its consent.
What you're experiencing
right now is not called stress.
It's called repercussions
for your actions!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stress is what you'll feel
when you go to jail.
He also says, "Pease just
let me age gracefully."
Well, uh, here's a beauty tip.
If you don't want to look old,
don't surround yourself
with teenagers!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You don't -- You don't have to
clap every time I yell,
'cause I'm never going to stop!
He also says, "I admit,
I [bleep] with all the ladies.
That's both older
and young ladies.
But tell me
how they call it a pedophile,
'cause that [bleep] is crazy."
Okay, two problems.
One, "ladies" and "crazy"
is a slant rhyme,
and you're better than that.
And, two, you married
a 15-year-old when you were 27!
That's the definition
of a pedophile!
We're not calling you
a pedophile.
Merriam-Webster is!
Next, he says,
"I'm tired of everybody
wanting a piece of me.
[Bleep]. I'm not
an ATM machine."
Fool, the "M"
stands for machine!
You just said, "Automatic Teller
Machine machine"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
R. Kelly also says, "I admit
that I've been underrated."
Okay, now,
here's where we agree.
You have absolutely
been underrated...
as a predator in our community.
You have been a criminal
for 20 years,
and you've been
getting away with it.
Know why? 'Cause all your
victims are black women.
Kanye West simply interrupted
Taylor Swift,
and he had to leave the country
for a year!
So, look, I'm sure
the song sounds great,
but you don't deserve
my attention.
What you deserve is jail time,
you slant-rhyming dummy!
This has been
"Amber's Minute of Fury"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!